big news in the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary and I am NOT
talking about beta or orcs dropping out
because nobody ever actually cared about
beta or orc except for the mainstream
media and they are wrong about
everything I'm talking about actually
consequential presidential campaign news
Elizabeth Warren has released the
details of her health care plan which
costs roughly fifty bazillion dollars we
will get into the economics of it and we
will examine the broader strategy of the
warren campaign she thinks you're all a
bunch of idiots then a democratic state
representative says something horrifying
about unborn babies surprise surprise
president Trump moves to Florida and so
much more i'm michael knowles and this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
huge news in the presidential race and
the bait oath they have to at least
enjoy this bado dropping at it's so so
fun and it's not to make fun of bado
it's to make fun of somebody else who's
a lot worse than bado a much greater
scourge to our country and a much
greater tool from the left but before we
get to that we've got to thank our
friends over at NetSuite let me tell you
something when you are growing a
business the number one problem that
stops businesses from growing is having
trouble knowing their numbers because
they'll keep their numbers on a
hodgepodge of business systems that's
where NetSuite comes in handy I've been
involved in a lot of businesses as
they're starting up businesses that I've
owned businesses I've just been a part
of daily wire is a good example
NetSuite by Oracle is the business
solution that will help you to manage
all of your numbers in an easy-to-use
cloud platform giving you the visibility
and control you need to grow with
NetSuite you save time money and
unneeded headaches by managing sales
finance and accounting orders and HR
instantly and you can do it right from
your desktop or your phone that is why
NetSuite is the world's number one cloud
business system it's so important
because the way I think a lot of
businesses start is they say okay I'm
I'm familiar with this system so I'm
going to use this for HR and I'm
familiar with this system so I'm gonna
use this for accounting whatever and
then you're it's it's a sort of laziness
even and what people forget is that time
is money and headaches are time and
money just put it all together let them
all talk to each other right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna wles
that's NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna
wles to download your free guide seven
key strategies to grow your profits
NetSuite comm slash Knowles
now speaking of startup organizations
that were not able to get past those
initial challenges the beta O'Rourke
campaign is officially over seems like
it barely began but it is officially
over I am NOT going to gloat
overall works campaign being over I'm
gonna miss bado or work he is hilarious
he was the doofus candidate in the
entire race he was skateboarding around
Whataburger parking lots he was filming
his dental hygienist while she was
poking around his teeth he was hilarious
he was great he reminded me of every
kind of whiny liberal guy who would hit
on your girlfriend when you went out of
town you know he was just like the Ark
title liberal progressive guy really
sensitive guy you know he's out of the
race now which is a huge slap in the
face not to his campaign staffers or his
donors or even himself it's a huge slap
in the face to the mainstream media the
reason that beta or work dropping out
matters the only reason that it matters
is because it highlights something that
we talk about every other day on this
show probably which is you should not
believe the press you should not believe
the mainstream media the reason you
should not believe the mainstream media
is not because they're awful and
terrible and mean people it's because
they're wrong all the time they lie
through their teeth the mainstream media
are dishonest the mainstream media are
hacks who spread lies if you're if
you've ever found yourself if you ever
had the privilege of finding yourself as
the target of mainstream media attacks
which has happened to me on on occasion
you the first thing you realize is not
your first reaction is not oh this is
awful how is low is me why is everyone
coming after me the first thing you
realize is I'm is a much more clear
observation about the press which is
they're wrong they spread lies I mean
imagine that that Nick Sandman kid the
kid with the red hat the Maggie hat in
DC who was there on a class trip he was
waiting for his bus and then these
lunatics started approaching him black
supremacist group the Hebrew Israelites
and this Native American leftist Looney
tune who walks up to him and starts
beating a drum in his face and there's
this kid who does nothing who just
stands there like sort of half smiling
unsure what to do and then the
mainstream media Washington
host new york times all those guys paint
him like he's a neo-nazi like he was
attacking these people the mainstream
media described the black israelites who
were screaming racial epithets at these
kids who were calling them all sorts of
names who were provoking them described
them as civil rights leaders they
described this actually insane Native
American leftist activist Nathan
Phillips banging a drum in the face of
the 16 year old kid for no reason
described him as a peaceful combat
veteran by the way he wasn't a combat
veteran just made it up out of whole
cloth and then described these kids who
were there on a class trip doing it
nothing standing still on the National
Mall which I think they're still allowed
to do describe them as hateful bigots
attack intimidating
that's the mainstream media they do it
time and time again they describe a 16
year old kid in a maggot as a threat as
an assailant and they describe Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi a rapist-murderer terrorist
as an austere religious scholar that's
what the Washington Post did last week
that's the mainstream media for you and
guess who the mainstream media's
favorite presidential candidate was four
months beta or roark big beautiful
glossy pictures in Vanity Fair beta or
work you know Tucker Carlson over at Fox
put together just a quick little montage
of the press's reaction when bado got
into the race I saw for the first time
just a month ago when he sat down with
Oprah and me and the rest of the people
in the audience thought wow this guy has
this dynamic positive energy yeah he has
that raw talent he is very kind of Obama
s and indeed though women voted for him
in the suburbs of Houston who hadn't
voted Democrat before because they had a
kind of better crush going on
you know he's wholesome and he's earnest
he's got that magic dust of course his
son his name Ulysses I love that that's
his sons and he has that gleam in his
eye somebody Evan Smith in The Texas
Tribune said seeing him is like it's
like a Jesus Christ Superstar seeing
this guy in front of people he's got
that celebrity or about him and in that
moment he was owning that none of that
is true
not as
single aspect of what they just said is
true he's not terribly charismatic he's
really awkward and weird and stiff and
goofy he's not like a celebrity
he doesn't make women swoon he's kind of
a weird guy he he's not Jesus Christ I
know the press actually said he was
Jesus Christ Superstar he's not he's an
ex congressman who lost a Senate seat
who lost a presidential race whose
skateboards around Whataburger parking
lot
he's also not that earnest I mean he
tries to affect an earnest persona he
doesn't believe in anything he changes
his views day-to-day at first he said
this was a few months ago he said we
will never take away your ar-15s we're
not gonna confiscate your guns then like
two months later he said hell yeah we're
gonna confiscate your ar-15
shortly after which he said hell yeah
we're gonna drop out of the presidential
race because he was going nowhere he
didn't catch on with anybody he actually
said in Iowa what he got onto a table
cuz this was his schtick for a while he
would stand on top of tables before
crowds of 15 sometimes 20 people and all
of whom were in the mainstream media by
the way and he said I want you to shape
me into the presidential candidate that
you want that is not the campaign theme
of somebody who's earnest somebody with
conviction somebody who's charismatic
somebody that people can fall
head-over-heels for that is the
presidential campaign theme of a hack
who doesn't believe in anything who's
just desperate for power
who says from the very first moments of
his campaign I was born for this I was
born to do this I'm in it to win it
he's one of the first candidates out of
the race so Beto's gone
adios beytagh hasta LaVista etymon oh I
don't I don't know I don't know much
Spanish but I do know much more Spanish
than beta O'Rourke
he's gone and I'm sorry for him but I
feel really great for the mainstream
media because once again they are proven
wrong there is actual news however in
the presidential race the actual news is
about Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren
has released the details
her healthcare plan that's not even the
big deal I mean we'll we will examine
the healthcare plan because it does tell
us a lot a better campaign but the
30,000 foot view the reason this matters
in presidential politics broadly is
because it means liz warren has made her
choice
liz warren has been debating now for
several weeks for several months
is she gonna take joe biden's voters or
is she gonna take Bernie Sanders as
voters is she gonna be the moderate
Harvard professor that she was for a lot
of her career circumspect academic
serious balanced or is she going to be
the radical workers warrior class
conflict Bernie Sanders communists those
were the two choices and she's waffled
she's vacillated between the two she's
made her choice she is going full
left-wing which means she believes that
Biden is done for she believes Biden is
over so she thinks that she needs to go
left to win the nomination
why because being a centrist didn't
allow Joe Biden to win the nomination it
actually hurt him and because she thinks
he's so weak he's not gonna be a
challenge so that she thinks his voters
are just automatically gonna go over to
her and she thinks that she's now got a
fight to win Bernie's voters the only
way she's gonna fight to win Bernie's
voters is if she gets down hardcore and
the leftist policies and if she uses
real numbers and she pushed puts forward
plans so it doesn't just look like she
stole Bernie's talking points but she
actually has her own real plans
Elizabeth Warren is now endorsing a full
government takeover of health care a lot
of Democrats have been talking about
this for the past several years really
they've been talking about this in the
fringes for a hundred years and now Liz
Warren who is possibly the front-runner
she's got all the momentum on her side
even if she's not number one in the
polls
she is endorsing it head-on no private
health insurance she is going full
Castro Fidel Castro not who Leon Castro
she's going far left she's been quiet
about her plans this whole time he's
been straddling that line now she's
admitting that she's on the left and the
other reason she's been quiet is not
just because she's had these two
personas the other reason is even if she
had
she's full left now if she gives that
the real numbers then she's going to
have to admit how she's going to pay for
it and the only way to pay for it is to
raise everybody's taxes so we have the
price the price that even liz warren is
admitting is 52 trillion dollars the
only advantage that liz warren has here
is that nobody has any idea how much
money fifty two trillion dollars is they
don't if you told people hey I've got a
million dollars here and a billion
dollars here and 52 trillion dollars
here okay three I dug three holes and I
poured in all that money million a
billion and fifty-two trillion visualize
that you would you would imagine like a
slightly smaller amount in the first
hole and then a slightly bigger amount
in the second hole and then a slightly
bigger amount maybe even a significantly
bigger amount in the third hole you
could never visualize the difference in
magnitude between a million dollars and
a billion dollars and fifty two trillion
dollars it's just you can't hold all of
that in your head and so what liz warren
is banking on is that anything with
iliyan basically means the same to
people when they hear it and so they
won't realize how insanely expensive
this plan is even SNL spoofed this plan
Saturday Night Live is in the tank for
Liz Warren and they have been for months
now
they love Liz Warren she's the only
candidate they don't really make fun of
they make fun of all the other
candidates but they don't make fun of
her because they like her all the
attacks that they throw on her or sort
of gentle attacks that actually make her
look good even they mocked Liz Warren
for this feature of her health care plan
for the fact that she's banking on
people not understanding how much money
a trillion dollars is twenty point five
trillion but other economists have said
it could cost 34 trillion right okay let
me stop you right there and we're
talking trillions you know when the
numbers are this big they're they're
just pretend okay so even here they make
the joke
say look look the reason is health care
doesn't matter because money is not real
and the numbers are so big you can't
even imagine what those numbers are and
the questioner who's apparently working
for the Connell Harris campaign that's
the setup she says I need to see the
math on that and then Liz Warren shows
her the math and says look I'm so smart
I understand this complicated math but
you don't cuz you're an idiot and I
could I'm so much smarter than you
so even when they make a pretty accurate
attack on her they have to then couch it
as a compliment to her because Saturn
and life can't just get the joke and
they can't just follow the comedy they
have to back their candidates let's not
forget when that same actress Kate
McKinnon when she was playing Hillary
Clinton in the 2016 election cycle and
then Hillary Clinton lost she played a
sad song on a piano very earnestly after
the election while everyone was crying
senator Ally that's the comedy but the
the joke they were trying to make at
least is real the numbers are too big
let's drill down into those numbers to
try to see we can clarify how much money
we're talking about previously Elizabeth
Warren said that only billionaires would
pay for her health care plan she would
raise the taxes on billionaires and then
they would pay for the plan here she is
here it's a hundred percent it doesn't
raise taxes on anybody but billionaires
and you know what the billionaire's can
afford it and I don't call them middle
class so billionaire that's where it
worked anyone under
that's right it's not paying a penny
more that's exactly right
okay that's a complete lie but let's
examine how gross a lie it really is the
400 richest Americans have a combined
net worth of two point nine six trillion
dollars okay we're not talking about
that's their income we're not talking
about raising taxes on their income or
anything like that that's all the money
they have is two point nine six trillion
dollars there are an additional two
hundred twenty one billionaires in
America now all of those billionaires
have less than two point 1 billion
dollars let's just assume for a moment
that all of the other billionaires in
America have 2.1 billion dollars which
they don't by the way so the actual
number of their wealth will be
significantly smaller than this but
let's if we just assume that then that
brings the total wealth of every single
billionaire in America to three point
four two trillion dollars it's actually
probably closer to three trillion but
let's say three point four two all the
billionaires in America have a combined
net worth of three to three point four
two trillion dollars if you confiscated
not just 100 percent of their earnings
so you you raise the tax rate on them to
one hundred percent which means they
stop working so I'm gonna make any money
but you raise let's say you raised it
two hundred percent then you showed up
at their doors with guns kicked in the
doors of their mansions stole all of
their property including the clothing on
their back if you did all of that you
could barely pay for 65 percent of even
one year of Liz Warren's health care
plan Liz Warren's health care plan fifty
two trillion dollar estimate over ten
years usually these plans are calculated
in the ten-year run so let's say one
year five point two trillion dollars you
took all the wealth of every billionaire
in America took every single penny they
have you couldn't pay for 65 percent of
one year by the way then what happens
after one year so you've paid for now 65
percent of one year of Liz Warren's
healthcare plan the billionaire's don't
have any more money they're not making
any more money
they have nothing so now what happens
once you get 65 percent of the way
through the year you need to start
taking money from other people but
you've taken by far the wealthiest
Americans and robbed them of all of
their money so now you're gonna have to
go for a whole lot more people not just
another six hundred people just a six
thousand people you're gonna have to go
for everybody
fifty-two trillion dollars over ten
years to put that in perspective we won
World War two for four trillion dollars
that's inflation adjusted in 2019
dollars it cost us four trillion dollars
to defeat the Nazis and Imperial Germany
and hold off the Russkies and secure the
world order again annualized inflation
adjusted we paid less than one-fifth per
year what Liz Warren wants us to pay for
health care to beat the Nazis and
Imperial Japan now how is Liz Warren
even saying this with a straight face
the way she's saying this with a
straight face is she's saying that she
will offset all of that money fifty two
trillion dollars in ten years by lumping
in Medicare and Medicaid and the state
contributions to Medicaid and the
Children's Health Insurance Program and
government health care plans because she
says we're we're already going to have
this government enforced socialist
medicine so you won't need all those
other health care plans okay fair enough
that still leaves thirty trillion
dollars in a budget gap the The Wall
Street Journal did a great editorial on
this if you want to have a really quick
concise breakdown that you're gonna read
go read their editorial 20 trillion
dollars 22 trillion just about she's
figured out how to take out of her
health care plan you've still got an
account for thirty trillion dollars here
to put that number in perspective the
entire GDP of the United States is
twenty trillion dollars the whole US
economy twenty trillion dollars we could
confiscate the entire economy of the
United States for one year by the way
there wouldn't be a US economy after
that
confiscate the entire economy of the
United States that's the end of the US
economy
you could confiscate that for one entire
year you would barely cover two-thirds
of just the budget shortfall over the
ten-year period the plan is an economic
joke it's a it's a farce nobody can take
this plan seriously from an economic
perspective but the nonsense economics
is only one political liability so it's
it's not even as though she puts out
this healthcare plan and then says okay
here it is you're gonna attack me for
this for all these there's crazy
economics that don't make any sense
that's not the plan is actually even
worse than that the other political
liability here is that Liz Warren's
health care plan would take away
Americans health care policies and they
hate that
Americans really don't like it when you
take away their doctor and when you take
away their health insurance and
especially when you tell them that if
they like their doctor they can keep
their doctor like Barack Obama did
Barack Obama took away health care from
a lot of people because of Obama care
which was a much more modest plan than
Liz Warren is proposing he told
Americans if you like your doctor you
can keep your doctor that was not true
many Americans lost their health care
because of that single act Barack Obama
lost 1,000 seats over the next several
years in our government federal state
and local 1000 seats the state houses
the Congress eventually the Senate he
lost everything he got to hold on to the
White House but he lost just about
everything else people really really
hate it when you take away their health
care because they view it rightly as a
matter of life and death so if you are
going to take away their doctor who they
really like or if you're going to start
rationing health care that's a big
problem the Liz Warren health care plan
would kick 170 million Americans off of
private health insurance bad enough
you're kicking half the country off
their private health care also it
Doris's rationing what is the rationing
the rationing is what Sarah Palin
referred to as the death panels which
the left mocked but they could never
explain why they were mocking it because
the death panels were real the death
panels were the Independent Payment
Advisory Board IPA B these were put
together by economists the same
economists who worked on the Liz Warren
health care plan that's why they're so
similar so the reason you need a
rationing is because health care is a
finite good health care is not a human
right it's not a natural right it's not
something we are endowed with our
Creator to have it's a technology it's a
commodity it's this thing that's only
been around for a hundred years in its
modern form and it's always involved
technology and other people's labor so
you can't just say I have a natural
right to healthcare because healthcare
involves other people's work it involves
other people's time it involves other
people's investments it involves other
people's ingenuity so how is health care
will always be a finite good it won't be
an infinite good the way that health
care is now doled out is we have health
insurance that pays for we have
hospitals we have prices for health care
that's usually covered by insurance but
sometimes people pay out-of-pocket if
you can't afford you can go to a health
an emergency room rather and you will
get healthcare you'll never be turned
away but it's not optimal but it's one
way that we now work out this problem of
this finite good that everybody wants
the Liz Warren plan would take away all
of those smaller forces that that
somehow keep this commodity in check and
they would give all of that to the
federal government so if US health care
spending exceeds GDP growth how will Liz
Warren pay for the program she says
quote I will use available policy tools
which include global budgets
population-based budgets and automatic
rate reductions to bring it back into
line that's a whole lot of political
gobbledygook to say I will ration care
this is what every socialist health care
plan has to do they will ration care
there will be very very long wait times
in which case people who were waiting
for surgery very often will die while
waiting for that surgery is it just
aren't enough doctors there aren't
enough beds the government just isn't
that good at running healthcare systems
or you'll have a black market for health
care I was in Cuba a few years ago I
visit Cuba I am driving around and I'm
walking around and I see Havana Hospital
it's famous Hospital all the left-wing
useful idiots will tell you health care
healthcare and Cuba's some of the best
in the world
because Cuba basically cooks their
numbers to make it seem this way so
there's the Havana Hospital anybody can
walk into Havana Hospital but you can't
get medicine this is what people in Cuba
told me you can walk in it's no problem
but they won't have medicine they won't
have towels they won't have pillows on
the beds you got to bring your own
band-aids got to bring your own syringes
you got to bring your own toilet paper
you have to bring everything because the
government has rationed care that's what
Liz Warren is gonna do she's going to
run for president during a time of
relatively great prosperity by saying
we're gonna have the same health care
system as Cuba in principle it'll be
better because we're richer and we're
starting from a much better position but
that's where we're headed it would also
raise the corporate tax rate would raise
it back to 35% from 21% this is a this
is pretty radical I know corporate tax
rates are a sort of minor campaign issue
Barack Obama himself campaigned against
the 35 percent tax rate it's just too
high
it's it's too high it makes America it
keeps America from being competitive
around the world
it ends up hurting American workers and
everybody in the country and Liz Warren
would raise even more taxes on top of
the 1% by taxing quote unrealized
capital gains so when you make an
investment and then you cash out that
investment you make some money you pay a
capital gains tax what Liz Warren's
gonna do is just tax you even if you
don't get the money yet so you've got an
investment and then Liz Warren is just
gonna make you pay a fee to even have
the investment as well as a 2% wealth
tax I'm Pete
more than 50 million dollars which is
just gonna send money overseas it's
gonna make people hide their money it's
gonna make people avoid the tax a
complete train wreck of a plan and this
is giving an opening to another
Democratic candidate who is creepin up
the polls because he's basically doing
the opposite of what Liz Warren history
we'll get to that in a second we will
also get to a disgusting comment on
unborn babies from a Pennsylvania
Democratic state representative
we'll also get to the collapse of Joe
Biden so much more but first we have got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
$10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you at the end
were Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro
show get them out well show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag coming up
on Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get everything and you get
the left is tears tumblr you're gonna
need that left is tears tumblr you're
going to need it because as Willie Brown
famous Democratic politician from
California helped to begin comel
Harris's career let's just put it that
way Willie Brown says that this Liz
Warren health care plan has destroyed
her chances at taking the White House
we'll see if that's true we'll see if
other candidates capitalize on it drink
up the leftist here as well you can go
to daily wire , we'll be right back
this warren plan is a train wreck and
she's just betting on you being too
stupid to realize what a trillion
dollars is much less fifty two trillion
dollars pete Budaj edge season-opening
this is pete Budaj edges chance
Pete Budaj edge who has also vacillated
in this race is he going to be the
moderate centrist is he gonna be the
radical generational revolutionary
candidate he's gone back and forth he
started out as the moderate nice
Midwestern guy then he became a radical
who told every Christian in the country
that they're terrible people and then
now he's going back and being the
moderate guy again because Liz wore and
is taking the radical train that the
track he now says he was saying this on
the political Showtime show the circus
that the race is going to become a two
way race between him and Liz Warren I
think this is getting to be a two-way
it's early to say it I'm not saying it
is it to it but I think but you see them
you see it's coming into focus you and
Warren yeah and certainly a world where
we're getting somewhere
is that world where it's coming down to
the two of us obviously there's a lot of
candidates and a lot of things can
happen but I think that as that happens
the contrasts become clear look that the
contrasts are real their substantive
respectful policy contrasts but they're
real first of all it's interesting you
say that right so you accept the notion
right now that it's kind of worn against
the field
really someone's trying to become the
alternative to Warren right now right
yeah I think it's it's shaping up that
way and so the former vice president
states is like in your mind at this
point already like gone I would say this
either he is the unstoppable frontrunner
and we can all go home or he's not and
anybody who's in this race is pure on
the assumption that that he's not first
of all you got to love these guys the
the questioner says so the vice
president of the United States he's over
Joe Biden is not the vice president of
the United States he was the vice
president of the United States now he's
a guy this is a sort of minor point but
it does tell you something when the left
just refers to President Obama they
always refer to President Obama they're
saying he's the real president you know
or Vice President Joe Biden is a real
vice president there's it's very quietly
very subtly
missing the current administration but
even beyond that even when they don't do
that
is very frequently people on both sides
will refer to the President or the vice
president even if they've they've
already left office but you'll hear the
right frequently will not do that
the reason shows two different views of
government one is a government in which
the president and the vice-president or
these unbelievable sort of imperial
figures that keep their titles forever
and the other is a much more American
view which is once you leave office you
lose your title the one exception to
this is senators senators style
themselves senator for life because
there are so many senators but you're
really not supposed to refer to ex
governor's ex presidents ex vice
presidents as the governor president
vice president people do it sometimes to
be polite but you're really not supposed
to there's only one president there's
only one vice president there's only one
governor of course the left wingers in
these political shows don't want to deal
with that
regardless Pete Moo de jedge is writing
off former Vice President Joe Biden he
is writing off Bernie Sanders why part
of this is wishful thinking he wants to
get them out of the way because then it
really is a two-way race between him and
Warren so long as Kamala keeps
collapsing it will be a two-way race
part of it is backed up by facts Bernie
Sanders health is now a major campaign
issue there's a new poll from ABC
Washington Post as a poll of Democrats
and Democrat leading independents
younger adults who are among Bernie's
strongest supporters are most apt to
think that he is in decent enough health
care to a health to serve six and ten of
them eighteen to thirty nine year olds
say that he's in ok health six and ten
forty percent of even the young voters
who are far and away most likely to
support Bernie Sanders
believe he's too unhealthy to serve as
president and 60% of older voters
meaning 40 and above think that bernie
is too unhealthy to serve as president
that's a big shift he bounced back after
that that heart attack within a week and
a half he was on that Democratic debate
stage and he was looking more energetic
and healthy than Joe Biden doesn't
matter he was already running as
an extraordinarily old candidate by the
standards of presidential politics that
heart attack is really going to hurt him
how about Joe Biden Joe Biden continues
to lead in most polls the polls are
falling though and he's losing ground in
the early States except for South
Carolina so creates this problem if he
loses Iowa loses New Hampshire he has no
momentum going into South Carolina
specially the electability argument is
all gone Biden is losing ground because
he's appears senile that's true he also
appears corrupt this is much harder for
Joe Biden to get past the hardest person
hit by impeachment is not Donald Trump
it's Joe Biden the impeachment vote that
they took last week was a party-line
vote those a vote by the way wasn't a
vote to impeach was a vote to begin an
impeachment inquiry which they'd already
begun that was a party-line vote no
Republicans voted for it
so it just shows people the same thing
they've already known since the Russia
hoax
and since stormy Daniels and since taxes
and now Ukraine they're just trying to
get Donald Trump out cuz they don't like
him
that's what Al Green said the first
Democrat to file an impeachment motion
against Trump they said if we don't
impeach Trump then he's gonna get
reelected so it's just a replay of this
nobody's changing their minds on this
but the more that Ukraine is in the news
the more that people are gonna hear
about the corrupt dealings of Joe Biden
not just in Ukraine but all over the
world yet again this weekend Joe Biden
with a straight face just lied to voters
and said that he had no knowledge that
his son was on that board in Ukraine
back to the Ukraine controversy your son
hunter you've been asked a lot of
questions about this but my question is
both of you have said you would not as
president have your children have him or
your children involved with foreign
countries my question is if it's not
appropriate if Joe Biden is president
why was it appropriate when you were
vice president well number one no one's
established that he did anything wrong
or that I've done anything wrong period
I carried out the policy of the United
States of America our allies the of the
International Monetary Fund the EU in
dealing with a corrupt prosecutor
number one I did not know he was on the
board of that company and in fact no
one's asserted on the board that was
illegal from ban the board or he did
anything wrong so the two major claims
that Joe Biden is making here that
hunter didn't do anything wrong and that
he didn't know that hunter was on the
board are just completely and
demonstrably false people have suggested
that what hunter Biden did was wrong
namely hunter Biden who just recently
resigned from the board it's like saying
I did nothing wrong
and by the way I'm sorry and I'll never
do it again also Joe Biden did know that
his son was on the board how do we know
that because hunter Biden told us in an
interview on Good Morning America just a
couple weeks ago did you and your father
ever discuss Ukraine No as I said only
time was after a news account it wasn't
a discussion in any way there's no buts
to this no we never did your dad said I
hope you know what you're doing I hope
you know what she's doing I do and I
said I do and that was literally the end
of our discussion okay look I never
talked to my dad about Ukraine I mean
the only time we talked about it was
when we web of anyway we weren't really
talking about it we were and it wasn't
about he didn't know it's just he told
me I better know what I was doing by
joining that Ukrainian board so we but
we talked about it okay we talked about
it once we didn't really I wouldn't say
we talked about it and we're never gonna
do it again we did they had a
conversation about him Joe Biden told
the hunter button rather told this to
the New Yorker magazine back in July
when hunter Biden joined the board of
Purisima his father found out about it
and said you better know what you're
doing because he obviously knew that it
looks pretty shady and looked pretty
dodgy and hunter Biden who's a complete
degenerate had no business being on this
board in Ukraine other than peddling his
father's influence cuz his father was
Vice President Joe Biden did know about
this but the biggest sign the biggest
sign here that Joe Biden is in trouble
is not that he's flailing it's not that
he's lying it's that he's tied with a
candidate who isn't even in the race
he's tied with one of the worst
candidates in American history Joe Biden
is now tied according to one poll with
Hillary Clinton I kid you not
Harvard Harris poll comes out
said if Hillary Clinton Mike Bloomberg
and John Kerry decided to enter the race
who would you support his candidate for
president joe biden got 19% so he's
still leading the pack
among this among Democrats Hillary
Clinton was in a close second
statistically tied 18% Liz Warren
distant third at 13% Kerry at 8
Bloomberg at 6 now with the race as it
is today 33 percent of Democrats
according to the same poll would support
Biden and Bernie's in second place at 18
percent but Hillary getting in totally
changes that what that means is
Democrats are very unsatisfied with the
field that they have they would even
choose Hillary Clinton historically one
of the worst candidates in American
history over Joe Biden before that we
say it's Budaj
who's gonna get it before we even say
the Buddha judge has a chance you have
to remember Buddha judge has big
problems to black voters make up 20% of
the Democratic primary base Pete Budaj
edge is polling at about 0% with black
voters the rosiest polls show he is four
percent black support most of them say
is zero one or two percent which means
Buddha judge has this incredibly
difficult obstacle to get over if he
can't get his numbers among black voters
up he's nothing it doesn't matter if he
wins Iowa it doesn't matter at all so
there's still a chance that Joe Biden
eats this out if he does he will be the
weakest frontrunner in my lifetime of
either party and this is a very very
weak field what the Democrats are
banking on is that because they have
such a weak field and because I strongly
suspect there's going to be a lot of
evidence of their wrongdoing in the 2016
election when we get the report from the
inspector general and the investigation
from John Durham which are kind of on
the back burner of politics right now
what they're hoping is that impeachment
will be a defensive measure we're an
early offense to attack Trump and
mitigate the damage from the IG report
and John Durham it's a bad idea
attention helps candidates if they're
just gonna make this race about Donald
Trump guess who's gonna win Donald Trump
attention helps candidates politics is
about
getting attention in so many ways now if
if the race is just a referendum on on
Donald Trump he is going to do very very
well that's a huge miscalculation
politicians can get bad sort of
attention and that sort of attention can
hurt them sometimes but when it's in a
race when you're not when you're not
showing an alternative it goes to the
guy who gets the attention some bad
attention the politicians are getting
came over in Pennsylvania with the state
representative Wendy Ullman Wendy Ullman
the state rep in PA was asked a question
about the handling of fetal remains
there was this bill on the table about
whether after an abortion for instance
fetal remains should be thrown out like
the trash or if they should be sold to
the highest bidder like Planned
Parenthood does and we're caught on
video doing or if they should be buried
or cremated like the anybody else's body
even for people who don't care much
about abortion this is a fundamental
question for society the question is who
do we think that we are what do we think
that we are representative Ullman made
very clear she thinks that we are
nothing but a mess on a napkin it refers
specifically to the product of
conception after fertilization which
covers an awful lot of territory I think
we all understand the concept of the
loss of a fetus but we're also talking
about a woman who comes into the
facility and is having cramps and
they're not to be not to be concrete an
early miscarriage is just some mess
honor and a napkin and I'm not sure
people would agree that this is
something that we want to take to the
point of ritual either cremation or
internment
yikes got Madame Defarge over here you
got a real old battle-ax in the PA
statehouse saying that babies are
nothing but a mess on a napkin and yet
in her defense
in her defense by the premises of
leftist politics she's right
another question why are all the crazy
abortion activists state politicians
named Wendy give this woman Wendy almond
you have Wendy Davis who is abortion
Barbie down in Texas it's kind of a
strange coincidence
regardless by the premises of leftism
this woman is right the premise is that
it's just a clump of cells babies just a
clump of cells the other premise of
leftism is that we're just a clump of
cells you see this in so many issues in
terms of the moral order what the left
tells us is if it feels good do it why
because we're just we're just a
combination of cells that have certain
sense perceptions and if you can
activate the pleasure sensors enough
that's a good thing and when you
activate the pain sensors that's a bad
thing and the transgender issue what the
left tells us is that we're just a clump
of cells and if we can change the
appearance of those cells then we will
have actually changed our identity we're
we're not something deeper you know what
the traditional view for all of human
history has been is that human beings
are soul and body we know that we're
body or body is really something to do
with us actually ironically the
transgender movement is in the one hand
totally exalting the body as all that we
are we're just material and then on the
other hand it's a total denial of the
body because it's actually saying what
our body is right now has nothing to do
with who we are my body if I look if I
look like a man but I say that I'm not a
man then I'm not really a man I have to
deny the physical and then I'll just
change the way my body looks and I'll
become a woman and then my body does
define who I am it's a very very
confused idea because it's beginning
with these very very confused premises
in which okay I mean even just think of
the premise of abortion women have a
right to kill their own babies because
women have this natural right given to
them by whatever creator spirit they
believe in or whatever supernatural
spirit they believe in we have this
right because we are dignified people we
have human dignity we deserve this right
to kill a baby because we don't actually
have any dignity or
he writes it all in we're actually just
a clump of cells in the abortion
question you see the opposite arguments
being made we have rights we have
dignity were worthy of great respect
were endowed with certain rights by our
Creator to deprive all those rights of
someone else because people actually
aren't anything other than meat and
flesh it's a totally bizarre completely
contradictory ideology and you can see
this woman is struggling with it in the
moment she says look I know this sounds
bad how can I make myself say this but I
have to say this cuz my ideologies says
so babies are just a mess on a napkin
you see she's obviously tortured by this
cuz doesn't make any sense I like that
she's being honest I like that we can
show honestly the total craziness of
leftism I like that we can show honestly
that the left thinks you're an idiot you
know that they think that they can tell
you that people are nothing but a mess
on a napkin we don't really believe that
they don't really believe that they
think they can force it down your
throats finally before we go I just have
to give a nod to Chuck Schumer for the
greatest tweet of the weekend he tweeted
out based on the news that Trump is now
moving officially to Florida his primary
residence was in New York now he's
moving to Florida is moving to Florida
because the taxes are much lower a lot
of people are leaving New York anyway I
mean I think 300 people move out of New
York
area per day because of the high tax
rates and people are moving largely down
to South Florida so Trump is gonna do
this for tax purposes Schumer tweets out
New York New York if you can make it
there you can make it anywhere Trump
can't Trump billionaire real estate
developer who's been a household name
around the world for 40 years who ran
and starred in the biggest show on
network television for 15 years and who
became the leader of the free world on
his first run for political office he
just can't make it you know according to
Chuck Schumer they think you're idiots
they think you're total idiots what they
don't realize is the people are actually
pretty smart people can see reality
people know when they're being lied to
they don't like it very much I think
it's why the left is getting so nervous
that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Doyle show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is nick Chien the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you